طيب يعني كان لدى البعض او خلق امل لدى
البعض من ان الامور قد تتحرك باتجاه
ايجابي مع فكره اقامه علاقات دبلوماسيه مع
اسرائيل حتى ولو انه معظم الدول العربيه
لم تقم علاقات دبلوماسيه كامله مع اسرائيل
حتى الان اولا لو من وجهه نظرك لماذا ترى
انه دول عربيه لا تقيم علاقات بشكل كامل
وهناك علاقات صارت بين اسرائيل ودول
العربيه الا يعد هذا كافيه بالنسبه
لاسرائيل
اغلب الدول العربيه اللي عن تحقيق علاقات
الدبلوماسيه مع فلسطين هو الاحتلال
المستمر المناطق الفلسطينيه ومن هو حق
المصير الفلسطينيين هذه
التي
رفضها الجامعه الدول العربيه تحت قياده
الملك عبد الله راح الملك المملكه العربيه
السعوديه ولا تزال هذه سياسه الجامعه
العربيه على رغم ان بعض الدول مثل اماره
العربيه المتحده والمغرب والبحرين تنعت عن
هذه السياسه واما فيما يخص كم يكفي
فالحكومه الاسرائيليه تقيم بشكل كبير
تحسين العلاقات مع تلك الدول التي ذكرتها
انفا ولكن كل الاسرائيليين يرغبون بعلاقات
كامله مع كل دول المنطقه وبهذا الخصوص
المملكه العربيه السعوديه هي بلا شك
الجائزه الاكبر بالنسبه لهم ورئيس الوزراء
نتنياهو لو كانت له امنيه واحده وحتى
امنيه زملائه ان المملكه علاقات دون ماسيه
كامله مع المملكه العربيه السعوديه
وهنا اود مره اخرى لسؤالي حول الامل الذي
خلقته لدى البعض اقامه علاقات مع اسرائيل
بان بين دول عربيه واسرائيل بانه قد يحرك
الملف الا تعتقد بانه لم يكن هذا صحيحا من
من كان المستفيد الابرز من اقامه مثل هذه
العلاقات هل واشنطن مثلا مستفيده منها
الاكبر من تحسين تلك العلاقات هو حكومه
اسرائيل والتي ارادت ان تظهر انها يمكن ان
يكون لها علاقات طبيعيه مع
الدول الجوار العربيه من دون حل المشكله
الفلسطينيه
ومن دون تحقيق تقدم وتجاه الدوله
وكما نقول هنا في الولايات المتحده تحصل
على كعكتك وتاكلها انت بالكامل
فهذه خطوه بعيده جدا عن المزيد من السلام
فيما يخص اسرائيل وفلسطين
نحيا الاسرائيليه هي الطريقه لتجاوز
الفلسطينيين ولتظهر بانني زعل الفلسطيني
من خلال هذه القراءه قلت اهميته من وجهه
نظر على الاقل بعض الحكومات العربيه الى
الحاد الذي يسمعه لهم بكسر اجماع جمع
الدول العربيه لتكون هناك علاقات كامله مع
اسرائيل على الر غم من عدم تحقيق اي تقدم
تجاه حل نزاع مع الفلسطينيين لذلك فبعيدا
ان اكون حركه تجاه السلام فكانت حركه
بعيده عن السلام وليست خاصه بحل السلام
وتحقيق السلام او حل النزاع الفلسطيني